in the hamlet of crack Croft you can
find a letter on the notice board just
outside of town in the letter A Man by
the name of William laments being away
from his darling Susan tragically
William and Susan's story does not end
with a happily ever after to discover
William's fate you'll need to travel
west of Kenbridge where you'll come to
an inconspicuous cave there's a
Whirlpool at the end of the path and
Diving through this pool leads you to a
body Williams body his body rests in the
mud with his travel supplies nearby
beside him is the final entry in a diary
which gives us a bit more context into
how he may have died my beloved the Moon
is not yet full yet such is my family's
fear that they have sent me away
prematurely I am frightened as a wolf I
am powerful but before the Moon is round
I am merely human Merlin knows what
beasts I may encounter in my present
form it does no good to dwell upon it I
hope I last this night and will be in
your arms before long William